Росія вже приймає заяви на громадянство
від жителів Донбасу. Цей центр у Ростовській області
відкрили за лічені дні після підписання
путінського указу про спрощене громадянство.
Отримати його можна всього лише за 3 місяці.
Навіть не потрібно особисто привозити документи.
Не треба й відмовлятися від українського громадянства.
На думку західних аналітиків, час для спрощення
видачі громадянства жителям Донеччини і Луганщини
обраний Москвою не випадково. Указ
Володимир Путін підписав наступного дня
після обрання Володимира Зеленського президентом,
тож це - свого роду перевірка нового глави держави,
яку йому влаштував Кремль, впевнені західні експерти.
- Це демонструє дуже важливий метод Путіна:
він постійно підкидатиме труднощі новому,
абсолютно недосвідченому президенту Зеленському.
А той, імовірно, спершу реагуватиме доволі жорстко.
Не так, як очікують багато його виборців на Сході та Півдні країни.
Указ Путіна явно порушує суверенітет України,
вважають у Європі. Адже подвійне громадянство
заборонено українською Конституцією.
Цілей може бути декілька. Від впливу
на внутрішню політику України до відвертого
провокування Києва й застосування військової сили Росією.
- Я вважаю, що Володимир Путін таким чином
намагається заявити про свої претензії
на жителів окупованих територій і наче дає зрозуміти:
якщо це російські громадяни, тоді завдання РФ -
захищати цих громадян. У крайньому випадку - від уряду в Києві.
У кроках Путіна експерти вбачають
старі дипломатичні сценарії Росії і проводять
паралелі з Абхазією та Південною Осетією.
- В Абхазії та Південній Осетії ми спостерігали
два елементи. Перше - це провокування Саакашвілі
на певну реакцію. Друге і принципове - це надання
громадянства жителям Абхазії та Південної Осетії.
Це було головною віхою на шляху проголошення
незалежності та відділення цих територій від Грузії.
Це той урок, який необхідно засвоїти й щодо Донбасу.
Зеленський натомість запропонував росіянам
можливість отримати додатково до російського
громадянство України. І цим він практично
підписався під незнанням Конституції України.
Путін тим часом щодня робить заяви про паспорти,
одна неочікуваніша за іншу.
- Якщо в Україні видаватимуть паспорти росіянам,
а ми в Росії видаватимемо паспорти українцям, то
рано чи пізно ми прийдемо до очікуваного результату -
у всіх буде одне-єдине громадянство. Це не можна не вітати.
До побачення.
- Українці, згідно з Конституцією, не можуть мати
подвійного громадянства. Тому питання
про дружнє отримання подвійного громадянства,
яке влаштувало би багатьох людей, не стоїть.
До речі, в Європейському Союзі, наприклад,
доволі багато британців стають бельгійцями тощо.
Але це не має нічого спільного з діями Москви.
Тут ідеться про геополітику й Донбас.
Небезпека, в якій опинилася Україна,
особливо велика в період міжвладдя - між строком
повноважень президента Порошенка, що спливає,
і початком правління Зеленського, підкреслюють аналітики.
Адже останній незабаром опиниться один на один
із Путіним на майбутніх перемовинах у Мінську.
Водночас Москва намагається дискредитувати
Зеленського напередодні виборів до Верховної Ради,
сподіваючись домогтися тріумфу проросійських сил.
Утім, це матиме наслідки і для самої Москви.
Так, у Євросоюзі вже заявили, що ця політика
не відповідає духу мінських домовленостей, кажуть експерти.